these are the images Boris Johnson
wanted voters to see on the last day of
campaigning a prime minister turned
milkman out dutifully delivering to the
public one employer so when he came on
board in Britain Prime Minister but
shortly before that Johnson and his team
were not so composed from one of the
minders come on good morning Britain and
deliver on your promise to talk to
patients and since Johnson was caught
off guard by a crew from ITV's good
morning Britain
anti-ben took refuge from reporters in a
freezer that was heroic work but equally
as staged was Labour leader Jeremy
Corbyn spinal errors on the campaign
trail
korban jumped at the chance to take a
swipe at his main political rival
[Applause]
[Applause]
Corbett will be hoping his message hits
home so far polls have not been looking
good for labour with most betting on a
conservative majority but bicky's have
seen a shift in recent days and carbon
is at much better odds of becoming prime
minister however there were no clear
favorites among the voters
if I'm honest with you there's no truth
there is no choice I don't like either
of the main candidates so I'm struggling
none of them tell the truth
[Music]
they just don't tell the truth they're
just out for themselves they're not out
for us they're out for themselves so I
will fight I will fight but I still
haven't made my mind up whoo yeah this
is largely a one issue election still
some are trying to focus on other
important topics
this latest mural by renowned Street
artist Banksy highlights the issue of
homelessness at Christmastime for many
of the purest people in the UK brexit is
the least of their concerns
well polls just opened in London about
an hour ago and our correspondent Bergen
Moss is covering a tall bigoted brexit
has great has created a highly divisive
atmosphere in British politics is that
being reflected in the election
campaigns well yes I mean it's really an
atmosphere of polarization just minutes
before we came on air there was a young
woman walking past she was on the phone
with her friend and she said I'm walking
past the polling station but I'm not
voting they are all liars I've spoken to
people who have rated labour for all
their life who were livid about Jeremy
Corbyn the leader of the Labour Party
and his brexit strategy and they said
they could not bring themselves to vote
Labour in this election I've speaking to
former Conservative MPs in Parliament
who described Boris Johnson the the
Prime Minister as a charlatan and a liar
so this really feeds through through
this whole atmosphere and through the
whole last weeks of the election
campaign polarization is a big issue
here in the UK now the polls have shown
that the the gap between the two parties
has been narrowing in the run-up to the
election do we have any idea of how the
country will vote today well for a long
time it really looked like it would be a
conservative majority however this gap
has narrowed of late so we are not quite
so sure whether Boris Johnson will get
the majority that he so desperately
wants in Parliament it could also be a
hung parliament
which would mean that most likely in
this case Jeremy Corbyn could also form
a government and he could be propped up
by by a smaller party so at the moment
we are not sure we do know that it looks
more likely that Boris Johnson will also
be the next prime minister but we don't
know yet in what word form exactly the
next Parliament will have okay well
what's going to happen after this
election period I mean there are a
couple of obvious scenarios
possibilities where will things go from
here particularly with braixen well if
we do have jeremy kuben as Prime
Minister he said that he wants to hold
another referendum on the whole brexit
issue that that would be the most likely
thing to happen under a Corbin
government if Boris Johnson wins he has
maintained and this was his mantra that
was quite simple and and easy with the
voters he said he's gonna get breaks it
done so he's promising by the end of
next January to lead the UK out of the
European Union however after that he
does face the arduous task to negotiate
again with the European Union this time
not about the withdrawal about the exit
but about the future paths of what kind
of relationship what kind of trade
agreement is the UK going to have with
the European Union Boris Johnson says
he's going to get it all done in a
matter of months however there are many
experts many critics here who are saying
well this is more likely taking years so
it's not unlikely that this whole brexit
debate is going to continue is going to
continue haunting this country very good
thank you very much DWS bigoted Maas
there in London well for more now let's
bring in our UK politics expert Alex
Forrest Whiting good morning Alex so
Election Day is here how's it looking
for the main parties well as we have
just heard the polls have been narrowing
throughout this campaign the
Conservative Party under Boris Johnson
have had a lead of around about 10
points and they are it appears still on
course to
win the election with lots of caveats
thrown in there the latest poll put them
with the majority of around about twenty
eight seats so they so a party needs
three hundred and twenty six seats to to
make government to be in a majority
however there are so many issues here at
stake for them and that there's the
issue of it being December it being cold
will people turn out and vote and also
the other issue of tactical voting which
is where people may decide look in my
particular constituency in this seat it
could be that we can get that a certain
MP a candidate outs a Conservative
candidate out by voting for another
party and that that's what they may do
so that is why at the moment there it's
still the possibility for it to be a
hung parliament exciting this election
was triggered of course by the
government's failure to decide the
brexit issue what have the parties been
telling voters about their plans to get
this issue settled once and for all
well we saw there with Boris Johnson in
that report that his one message has
been get brexit done and everything that
the Conservatives have gone out and done
particularly with Boris Johnson has had
those three words on their campaign
whether he's driving a digger with those
words on whether he's baking a pie with
it across his apron putting a rabbit
pulling it exactly everything is get
brexit done because that is what they
think will get through and is getting
through particularly to two voters here
would normally perhaps vote for the
opposition party the Labour Party
because that the feeling is that many
people are sick of brexit and they want
to get it done so that is what they want
to do they're under pressure from the
brexit party to get brexit done then we
can look at the opposition party the the
Liberal Democrats saying no we want to
revoke article 50 of the Lisbon treaty
that means we want to reverse this whole
thing we want to go back to the
beginning
forget bricks it ever happened and then
the Labour Party now that's the most
interesting they have had a huge amount
of a torturous debate over what do they
want to do with brexit finally they have
decided that they would like to
renegotiate a new deal
with Brussels and then put it to a vote
to the people so a second referendum to
the people to decide with with Jeremy
Corbyn the leader saying that he will
not come down on either side leaving it
completely open because many believe
that he himself is actually Pro brexit
okay that of course is contingent on the
EU being willing to negotiate again if
Johnson's conservatives do win as the
poll number polls right now suggest what
will happen next well he will do what
he's been promising which is to get
brexit done so he's expected to bring
his his deal his withdrawal agreement
back to Parliament even before Christmas
to try to get that through Parliament
with the aim of getting the UK out of
the EU by the 31st of January now that
was the latest deadline that Brussels
gave the UK if that then happens it's
not all over as many people are saying
the Conservatives are saying that's it
of course it isn't the UK then has to
agree a future trade deal with the EU
Boris Johnson says that can be done by
the end of next year most experts are
saying it absolutely cannot be done so
either way
Briggs it isn't over yet I'm afraid not
Alex Forrest whiting thank you so much
for filling as in